the formal swearing-in of ariel armory
as haiti's new prime minister
is an attempt to end days of uncertainty
following the assassination of president
javanelle moise
acting prime minister claude joseph
appeared to be in charge
following the brazen attack on moise he
stepped aside to allow henri to take the
reins
the 71 year old neurosurgeon is calling
for unity
but he's facing a long list of social
and political issues
we will create a secure reliable and
stable environment to facilitate
political activities throughout the
country
we will expect massive participation in
the next presidential elections
the highest participation of citizens of
voting age
omri is appointed his cabinet with the
goal of leading haiti to new elections
that's been problematic previously
leading to maui's ruling by decree
but haiti's future may depend on a free
and fair vote
this government won't think for the
people they're unpopular they're only
thinking for the elite again
at the expense of the haitian people we
can't expect anything serious from this
government
we say to this new government welcome
because we the haitian people
we want actions from them we would like
the new government to solve the crisis
of the country
to solve the problems of slum
neighborhoods
many haitians see these as dangerous
times and henry's international backing
is regarded by
some as a problem anybody they sort of
back or anoint or push
is going to be seen with a lot of
skepticism by the haitian people i think
people are are very wary of
international community involvement in
haiti at this time
but of course they want aid but they
they don't want the interference
and uh meddling memorial services for
fifty three-year-old juvenile moist are
being held
even as the investigation into his
assassination continues
on tuesday haitian authorities made more
arrests including people said to be
police officers
but they appear no closer to finding out
why he was killed
the cowardly assassination of the
president of the republic
constitutes a real national drama we
have a duty to consider it as such
including those in hiding and in any
counter conflict
while the international community is
pushing this impoverished nation to hold
elections
others say voting won't solve haiti's
problems
many key institutions have failed gangs
control large parts of port-au-prince
and the economy lays in ruins the stakes
for haiti
couldn't be higher andy gallacher al
jazeera